[Music]
friend your question is when we have a
permanent base on the moon where will
the astronauts get air to breathe I'm
sure it makes sense to you that air is
something that we consume and it would
be a lot of effort to actually bring air
tanks from Earth and actually launch
them up onto the moon one of the
questions I can ask you is where do you
think the astronauts are getting air
right now to breathe on the
International Space Station we don't
actually take up giant tanks of air to
the space station they get it from water
if you run a very strong electrical
current through water you can separate
it into hydrogen and oxygen oxygen of
course is the most important gas that we
need to breathe so the way the space
station gets air is it takes water and
breaks it up into those two gases and
actually uses the oxygen for people to
breathe now we can do the exact same
thing on the moon and so your next
question would be well well doesn't it
take a lot of energy to bring water up
there as well you have to bring all
these water tanks this is one of the
reasons we were most excited to find
evidence of a lot of ice underneath
parts of the Moon up by the poles of the
moon there are craters that are very
well shaded from sunlight and they get
very very cold and we found evidence of
more water in the lunar soil in those
craters near the poles than we ever
expected that means if you had
astronauts up there and you actually had
the bases near the poles of the moon
there would be stores of ice and
therefore water that you could actually
tap into you could actually turn that
water into air for the astronauts to
breathe without ever bringing anything
up from the earth you could actually be
independent on the moon itself and
there's another really important thing
that you can make out of water by
separating it into oxygen and hydrogen
and that's rocket fuel rocket fuel today
liquid rocket fuel is the combination of
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen so not
only would you have air to breathe from
the water but you could make your own
fuel this is one of the things that
we're investigating now not only
colonizing the moon but also thinking
about sending people to Mars
you send people so far away they have to
be independent and they even have to
make their own fuel to get back and we
think we can do that if we can find
water one of the great questions is why
would there be ice on the moon the moon
seems very dry there's no atmosphere how
could there be
or even frozen underneath the soil well
we think that what's happened over
billions of years is that many different
comets and asteroids have collided with
the moon you can see all the craters on
the surface and asteroids and comets
both contain a decent amount of water
now most of that water probably just got
vaporized and flew off the moon entirely
but some of it actually turned into ice
and the important thing about these deep
craters near the poles is that they're
shaded from sunlight sunlight would
actually just disperse that ice and
actually turned into vapour but in the
dark shadowy craters the ice accumulates
over time and so you actually have a
buildup of ice underneath the soil
[Music]